（私はある日思ってしまった）
（クラッカーを水の中で撃ち込むとどうなるのか）
（クラッカーは中に入ってある軽い紙テープを2mくらい軽く吹き飛ばす力を持っている）
（水中の中でクラッカーを撃ち込むとどうなるのか）
（少しィ..）
（オシャレである）
今ご覧になっていただいたと思うんですけども
俺がやった時はもっとすごかった
ガラスのコップがぶっ飛んでくくらいすごかったんですけども
今やった時も
ここに水がかかるくらい
すごい、水が跳ねたということで
クラッカーはね水の中ですると
ものすごい爆発力があることに僕は気づいてしまった
だって冷静に考えてみると
中に細かいロールテープが入ってるわけじゃないですか
あれって軽いんですよ
ただの紙ぺらをあんだけ遠くに飛ばすということは
すごい力が入ってることに僕は気づきました
というわけであんまり皆やってないと思うんですけど
今回はクラッカーを水の中に撃ち込むとどうなるのか検証していきたいと思います
用意する物はこちら
これ多分普通のやつよりかなり力が強いみたいです
こいつはやべーぞ
はいこちら、BIG クラッカーです
これも、もうやばいんじゃないんですかね
かなり力が強そう
で、次がこちらです
予想以上に大きいクラッカー
これは中身だけ出ちゃったんですけど
まだ残ってるんですよね
なんで中身だけ出たんだろう
これ何か乗せたらぶっ飛んでいきそうだな
こんなもんでしょ
というわけでこちらの予想以上にデカいクラッカーも期待でございます
最後はこちらです
迫力最高と書いてありますね
店の中で売ってるので多分一番強いであろうクラッカーでございます
というわけで今回こちらのクラッカー達を使って
水中で撃ち込むとクラッカーはどんだけ強いのかを皆さんにわかってもらおうと思います
いや、オイラやった時ね
もうほんとにねガラスコップがぶっ飛（ry
いきます
3,2,1
water
フライパンの水が強すぎるので
さすがにクラッカーさんも厳しそうな顔をしてました
では改めて
3,2,1,  water
もっと強くなかったっけさっき
びちゃびちゃ
まあ、たかがノーマルクラッカーすよ
本番はこっからです
これは威力が格段に違うと思われます
いきます
ﾊｯﾊｯﾊtｩﾊｯﾊｯ
これこれこれ
これですよ
もう何が起きても僕は何もわかりません
いきます
わー怖い怖い怖い
このサイズはやばいぞ
いきます
はぁ!?
うぇえあひいいいいい
怖くてわからなくなってきたよ
何が起きた今
耳痛
小さめのフライパンでいきます
3,2,1
どこが一番ひどいかって俺の足元だよ
地味にすごいなこれ
もう一発いきましょう
いきます
あああああああああああああ
最後はコチラのなんか強そうなやつ
これが多分最強級レベル
（その時はじめは思った）
これ何に使うんだろう
撃ちまーす
あなた一番弱いよ多分
もう直接いきましょう
お前ぇ！！！
～＾ED＾～
ででででん